i've got to do a better job getting us
ready to go gary and and really it was
in all three phases it wasn't good
enough um this loss will demoralize us
only as much as we allow it to it's
going to be embarrassing sick to your
stomach about it
but we do have two games left and we've
got to find a way to respond and rebound
on a short week you know not really a
short week but but this week um as we
get ready for the seahawks but that was
uh very humbling and it's going to be
humbling but
we're going to move forward and that's
exactly what we'll do that's all i know
how to do
you know there's an attitude embedded in
sean mcvay's comments that the jets are
hot garbage and uh look they're still an
nfl team they're still an nfl team they
hadn't won a game but they're still an
nfl team and you got to be ready
every day when you play an nfl team
rodney harrison was talking about this
last night in the digital thing that we
tape after the halftime segment and you
know he said i put this on the players
because they have to be ready the coach
has to have the players ready the coach
has to sense
in the locker room that the guys are
being a little lackadaisical that
they're lollygagging the week of
practice they think this is just a
little pre-christmas right it's
christmas week let's just check this box
it's the jets they stink they just got
blown out by the seahawks they had their
chance to win a game they blew it this
is going to be easy we're the rams well
what what uh what a a a stark reminder
right for the rams that you can lose any
given sunday and now their chances of
winning the division have been screwed
up significant well that's the big thing
is like you said first off it's the nfl
the difference between the worst team
and the best team in the league is like
a handful of plays and you know i think
college football sometimes you know
distorts our perception of those type of
matchups right in college football you
see a team that's nine and four playing
a team that's one in 13 you go well
they're going to win by 50. that doesn't
mean crap in the nfl to your point so
you're exactly right there's still a lot
of big time players on that jets
football team and the rams
listen lack of play-making on the
offensive side of the ball is just an
issue you know jared goff is not capable
of making anything happen when mcveigh's
special doesn't work it's the same old
same old and you know they yeah they're
down 17 nothing you let up a block pun
and then the following drive jared goff
throws an egregious horrible
interception and now it's 13 nothing and
i don't care who you are i mean you make
mistakes like that you're you're going
to be in trouble and the rams didn't
play well made a lot of mistakes
yesterday i i would love to attach sean
mcveigh to a lie detector test or at
least go get him drunk and find out what
he really thinks about jared goff
right
um they kind of got pushed into the
corner to sign him to that long-term
contract and
it
he he's yeah
we said it we don't need to say it again
right i don't think he's the quarterback
they need and it showed itself yesterday
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports